c'est le 27 octobre 1946 alors ce que la
constitution de la quatrième république
fut publié au journal officiel que
figurait en son préambule les mots
suivants la loi garantit à la femme dans
tous les domaines des droits égaux à
ceux de l'homme
c'est l'article 3 nous avons donc choisi
en france d'inscrire dans la
constitution que la femme serait l'égal
de l'homme
j'imagine donc que depuis 70 ans on a
quand même eu le temps de tout mettre en
place pour que nous puissions parvenir à
cette égalité quoi à la situation est
encore merdique et inégalitaire après
soixante dix ans ça le chili alors
attention
j'exagère un poil sur le dernier siècle
d'immenses progrès ont heureusement été
réalisé en france et l'histoire
politique et sociale de cette période
reflète un mouvement d'émancipation
progressif des femmes luttent après
lutte
les femmes ont gagné des droits et
c'était pas couru d'avancé parce que
comme des corneilles on vient de loin
alors on vit chaque jour comme le
dernier et c'est toujours intéressant de
se rappeler qu'en moins de cent ans
un gros travail a été fait sur l'égalité
homme femme d'un point de vue législatif
dans les grandes lignes
depuis 1944 elles ont pu récupérer le
contrôle de leur parole citoyenne avec
le droit de vote depuis 1965 le contrôle
de leur vie professionnelle
puisqu'une loi les autorise alors à
exercer une profession sans
l'autorisation de leur mari
et depuis 1975 le contrôle de leur corps
avec la loi veil autorisant
l'interruption volontaire de la
grossesse ivg
alors là bien sûr vous dites que c'est
évident mais le truc c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
puisqu'on est né avec ses acquis on
réalise pas forcément qu'il y à 75 ans
ce qui est peut-être l'âge de votre
grand-mère qu'une femme n'avait pas le
droit de voter et le combat n'est pas
près de s'arrêter car il ya toujours un
écart entre le moment où une décision
est prise d'un point de vue législatif
et le moment où elle finit par être
parfaitement appliqué aujourd'hui le
gros point noir de la france en matière
d'égalité hommes femmes dans les
classements internationaux concerne le
milieu professionnel
alors cela passe entre autres par un
problème de parité homme-femme
concernant les postes à responsabilité
je vous invite à aller regarder le
visage des patrons du cac 40 ou même
celui de leur conseil d'administration
de nombreuses lois ont donc été votée à
l'assemblée nationale pour garantir
cette parité et certaines concernent
tout particulièrement la parité hommes
femmes en politique
un françois hollande lui-même s'était
engagé dans ses promesses de campagne a
montré l'exemple et à deux ou trois
remaniements près le dernier en date est
représentatif d'une parité parfaite
bravo comtois mais quand on sort du
premier cercle ministres et secrétaires
d'état pour redescendre sur mes
chouchous que sont les députés
là ça pue la larme a été tirée par le
haut conseil et l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes lors de la
publication de son guide 2016 de la
parité qui a relevé qu'en juin 2016
seuls 26 2 % des élus de l'assemblée
nationale sont des femmes pour donner
meilleure et des soins classement de 191
pays la france se place à la 60e place
au niveau de l'irak
alors perso autant je me réjouirais
d'être au même niveau que l'irak dans un
classement sur la qualité du sable ou
sur le niveau d'enseignement annuel
autant dans un classement international
sur la parité ça craint est ce qui est
vraiment chaud c'est qu'il ya quatre ans
on était trente sixième alors ça peut
vous rassurer on n'a pas fait marche
arrière en avant juste moins vite que
les autres ce qui maintenant que j'y
pense en soi n'est pas hyper rassurant
non plus et ce n'est pas faute de
légiférer puisqu'une loi de 2014 prévoit
le doublement des sanctions financières
imposées aux partis politiques qui ne
présentent pas un nombre égal de femmes
et d'hommes candidats pas de chance pour
cette année puisqu'elle ne rentrera en
vigueur qu'à partir des législatives de
2010 est comme d'habitude en fait on
légifère mais on tarde à appliquer mais
le problème c'est que ce n'est pas le
cas quand politique injuste parlé en
premier puis ce qu'ils sont supposés
montrer l'exemple
car ils sont à l'initiative des lois
visant à corriger les problèmes
d'égalité dans le problème de parité
touche énormément secteur encore une
fois selon le haut conseil à l égalité
pour la partie média les femmes
représentent 40 9,6 pour cent de
l'auditoire
mais seulement 8% des présentateurs pour
le sport elles sont 34 % des licenciés
pour 10,5 pour cent des présidents de
fédérations et pour partie éducation
elle représente 55 2 % des étudiants
pour 15,6 pour cent des présidents
d'université en revanche elle surpondère
certains secteurs et elle occupe 80% des
emplois précaires
on aurait pu continuer comme ça pendant
un moment là toi d'ailleurs fait une
excellente vidéo sur le sujet du youtube
game par exemple les femmes se
représentent la catégorie beauté mais
sont quasi absentes de la catégorie
humour il ya très peu de filles dans le
classement des 100 premiers youtuber
français sur cent il y en a seulement
une dizaine et dans cette poignée de
femmes deux font de l'humour toujours
dans ce classement des 100 premiers
youtuber sur la dizaine de filles
présentes 80 % font de la beauté l'autre
grosse partie dans l'égalité
professionnelle concerne l'égalité des
salaires à poste équivalent et là on
n'est vraiment pas bon selon le rapport
annuel du forum économique mondial
concernant les inégalités femmes hommes
la france se retrouve à la 132e place
sur 145 pays en matière d'égalité
salariale
je ne vous refais pas la blague sur
notre position dans la liste mais savoir
qu'on se situe sur le plan des
inégalités salariales
derrière l'azerbaïdjan le tadjikistan le
zimbabwe où la russie fera peut-être
évoluer les idées reçues que l'on a sur
la place de la femme dans ces pays bien
dans l'autre c'est selon ce qui devient
vraiment problématique c'est que
forcément quand l'accès au sommet de la
pyramide de l'emploi ou un salaire
correct est inégale la retraite le
devient aussi si l'on se fie à l'étude
de l'adn es direction de la recherche
des études de l'évaluation et des
statistiques
publié en 2015 les femmes perçoivent une
pension de retraite moyenne 2 967 euros
brut par mois contre 1600 10 euros pour
les hommes soit un écart de 40 % ce
dernier tend à diminuer lorsque l'on
tient compte des pensions de réversion
ou du minimum vieillesse mais l'atteinte
ou même 26% à la lumière de tous ces
chiffres
j'espère que vous comprenez mieux
l'initiative d'origine islandaise qui
avait rayonné jusqu'en france et fait
grand bruit dans les médias en invitant
les femmes à arrêter de travailler le 7
novembre 2016 à 16h34 pourquoi cette
date parce qu'au vu de l'écart de
salaire femmes hommes
il s'agit de la date symbolique à partir
de laquelle les hommes auront gagné ce
que gagnent les femmes en une année
l'idée c'était alors de mobiliser un
maximum de monde pour attirer
l'attention
entre autres des futurs candidats à la
présidentielle on est donc l'un des pays
d'europe qui rament le plus sur la
partie et gaieté économique alors
heureusement notre classement global et
notre honneur reste sauf grâce à de
bonnes performances dans d'autres
domaines comme par exemple l'égalité
d'accès à la santé ou à l'éducation
et enfin ça c'est pour le moment parce
que manque de bol une minorité de plus
en plus bruyante semble motivé à revenir
sur certains droits fondamentaux des
femmes par contre couché que son cousin
c'est toujours bon et trop souvent des
hommes politiques puisqu'on a vu la
répartition femmes hommes à l'assemblée
nationale semblent prêts à prendre des
décisions et voter des lois qui
concerneront les femmes notamment sur la
loi veil et je comprends que ça puisse
rendre dingue
muriel robin d'ailleurs très bien résumé
son point de vue lors d'un coup de
gueule dans l'émission salut les
terriens de thierry ardisson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sachant que plutôt que de s'occuper de
réactualiser le débat sur l'avortement
en fronçant les sourcils faire la chasse
au burkina coucou manuel valls ou contre
le planning familial
coucou marion maréchal-le pen les
politiques pourraient s'occuper d'autres
problématiques qui touchent les femmes
et entraîne malheureusement parfois la
nécessité d'apporter un plutôt que de
s'intéresser en fait à ce que les femmes
devraient faire ou ne pas faire
l'état devrait s'intéresser à ce qu'il
pourrait faire pour elle comme par
exemple endiguer l'explosion du nombre
de viols ces dernières années avec un
nombre d'agressions qui a augmenté de 18
% entre 2010 et 2014
juste pour que vous prenez bien
conscience de chiffres on se parle de 12
1768 viols dénoncés à la police en 2014
soit un viol déclaré toutes les 40
minutes et je ne parle que des viols
déclarés pas de toutes les victimes qui
n'osent pas porter plainte parce que
sinon on monte à un viol toutes les 9
minutes c'est énorme même si on peut
toujours aller plus loin sur un plan
législatif et serrer la vis sont plutôt
certaines mentalités
certains comportements voir vision
parfois archaïque de la société qui
convient de faire évoluer si on veut
espérer avancer vers une meilleure
égalité entre femmes et hommes en france
et ça commence par des choses aussi
basiques qu'améliorer la répartition des
tâches ménagères dans le couple ou bien
que de ne pas associer le ministère du
droit des femmes à souhait de la famille
et de l'enfance lors du premier
remaniement venu parce qu il ne manque
plus que le ministère de la cuisine pour
que le combat soit parfait plutôt que
d'être en retard
soyons de nouveau en avance parce que
pour montrer l'exemple et faire la leçon
au reste du monde
il faudrait déjà que nous soyons
exemplaires j'espère que cet épisode
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à le faire
tourner c'est le cas et a lâché un
commentaire on impose bleus pour aider
au référencement
si le concept d'égalité homme femme ne
semble pas logique je t'invite à
regarder ce coup de fil sur le féminisme
de simone de beauvoir
ça met préféré justement description en
grand merci aux types heures qui
soutiennent le projet et big up à toutes
les personnes qui soutiennent la chaîne
en partageant son contenu pouvait me
suivre sur facebook twitter c'est un
chat love peace ciao